at the start of each year apparently I
invest $1,000 in my superannuation fund
okay stop right there
superannuation what does it mean well
from the name of the thing itself you
can already tell an you a ssin it's
something that you do every year so this
is why just to make it really clear it
says at the start of each year just in
case you didn't notice that right now
what is the super in superannuation well
I keep on adding money in and I'm
actually required by law not to take it
out so it's like the ultimate investment
I just throw money in there and
hopefully by the time I retire it's nice
and large and I can use that I can draw
from those funds for the rest of my
retirement that's the theory anyway
that's what happens at the start of each
year at the end of each year it gains
interest I'm handing this money over
they're putting it into like shares or
something like that and hopefully it
grows question part 1 find the
expression for the amount in my account
at the end of 3 years now just to let
you know I've structured this just like
an HSC question would do it so these two
parts as you can see are connected this
is the real question part 2 we're going
to use part 1 is kind of like a
milestone to get there okay so to begin
with just like I usually do I'm gonna
write down the important pieces of
information in the question just so that
I know which are the vital you know
details so I've got $1,000 and that's at
the beginning of the year
please note that the question says
beginning of year end of year so those
things are different
and then I've got 5% interests I
probably should have put this in its per
annum for this case if they haven't said
anything but they'll almost certainly
tell you it's per year its per month its
per quarter whatever it happens to be
okay
so I've written five percent per
interest and that's at the end of the
year okay so when they say find an
expression for the amount in mr. whose
account at the end of three years this
question tends to worth about two marks
and then once you go through step by
step and build what is happening here
okay
so I'm gonna say this is my answer to
Part one let a and and I'm using this
subscript here because that's what we do
in series in the sequences notation we
mean hey look that's the enth amount
right so let's let that be the amount in
the account after n years okay after n
years so what happens after one year
well in the first year I start off its
January one I put a thousand dollars in
okay but a thousand dollars while that's
where I start that's not what happens at
the end of the year I get interests on
December 31st BAM they give me my five
percent okay so what will I do to this
to turn it into what it should be by the
end of the year I think multiplying by
1.05 is probably the easiest most direct
way to say okay so there you go interest
applied that's a 1 now I could go ahead
and evaluate this number it's a thousand
and fifty dollars right but because what
I'm actually trying to do is get an
expression for what's happening at the
end of three years I'm actually going to
leave it expand it out like that because
it will form a pattern watch a two
I start off the second year with the
amount I had before so I'm literally
gonna say that a one but then what do I
do
well January 1 takes over and what
happens January 1 I add in $1,000 I make
a deposit okay and then the year passes
and then at the end interest gets
applied now what does the interest get
applied to the whole thing right
everything in the account so I'm going
to put some big fat brackets there and
I'm going to say that multiplies I 1.25
are you with me so far
yes so now I know what a 1 is by the way
it's a thousand times 1.05 plus a
thousand and that gets multiplied by
1.05 you with me can you see a pattern
starting to form on the next line I'm
going to just expand out this first
number is the first $1,000 that I put
into the bank at the beginning on
January 1st right
how many lots of interests have been
applied to it the 1.05 happens twice
here the first time and then here the
second time that's because that amount
of money has been in there for two years
so it's got to lots of interest on it
then there's this guy
and that's only got one lot of interest
does that make sense
because only been in there for a year
how you going so far yeah yep now what's
happening here I'm forming a GP aren't I
right because I have this common ratio
and to get to the next term I'm just
gonna multiply by that common ratio
again let's do the lasts in this case
the third year right the last one so a 3
is going to be equal to well I start
with a 2
and then what happens on January 1st I
deposit $1,000 and then in here passes
and then on December 31st interest gets
applied now I know it might feel a
little bit long in the tooth to say it
out like this but you must understand
what equation you're actually forming
and know what all of these numbers mean
not just be able to write down the
numbers okay so now I'm ready I can put
all this in it is a fine question so you
know what the next one I'm just going to
write it like this
okay so just quickly before we move on
what is this first thing that I've
written down it's the first deposit I
put in can you see why it's the first
deposit do you see what's being applied
to it three lots of interest because
it's been in there for three years yeah
this is the second lot I put him it's
been there for two years
here's the last slot it's been from
January 1 to December 31st okay
I know it seems counterintuitive it took
me a long time to accept this but if you
had a single bank account with a
thousand dollars in it as compared to a
thousand bank accounts or with $1.00 in
them there's no advantage to putting
them all in one big heap they actually
earn the same amount of interest all
separately so you can always think of
this one account as three separate
accounts each earning their own interest
are you okay with that